tell us a little bit about yourself
christian well uh there's not much to me
other than me being a lost well then
goodbye
i'll be leaving you now yes it's nice
knowing you the most uh boring well
there's not much to me he said
no besides what what what you said
something i'm a locksmith that's
one interesting thing about me yeah uh
are you good at being a locksmith oh i
think so uh usually
they say that the complaint that you get
if you're a good locksmith is you did
that too fast i should have taken you
longer so if you're making a key for a
car or if you're like trying to break
into
uh the customer's house because they
left their keys inside and it takes you
two minutes and then they complain
they're like shouldn't that have taken
you longer
do you ever try and stretch it out a
little bit just to um make it look more
impressive no because i feel like it's
more impressive when you take when you
the quicker you are the faster you are
yeah so i've that's been my approach to
lovemaking my entire life uh
you know that was just there and i did
it i don't care um
so let me ask you something because i
have i have questions
that intrigue me uh locksmiths can
commit heinous crimes if they want you
have a superpower which is you can go
i'm guessing what to any door any car
and you can get in within maybe a minute
or two yeah like 90
of uh residential doors and commercial
doors christian what keeps you from
committing robberies on a massive scale
my wife oh your wife yeah she's going to
be in check that's good yeah that's good
all right well good yes
that's good so she is she's the moral
compass she's the one that says yeah
yeah without her and her um input in my
life
i don't know where i would be
that's a very sweet thing to say because
when i look into your eyes i see a man
who'll do anything uh you know to to
profit in this world and you have the
skill to do it you can get it now let's
let's be honest here can you really
break into anything let's just say
residential can you get into any house
uh yeah mainly because especially on
this side of the country
90
of the locks are on two major keyways or
brands and we have tools here i got i
got a little tool here this is my
favorite one to use it's called the
lychee and this basically you just put
it in and you just feel every pin until
it you pick it you go one by one and it
actually reads you the cuts christian
could you teach me how to do this i
could i don't know if i want to though
because no no
for the heinous crimes you may come in
no what crimes
here's when i wake up with him in my
bedroom in the middle of god oh trust me
i'm here i've been in there i've watched
you sleep uh it's something i do with
all my employees
um so scary the first time yeah
you were a night mask it's weird uh and
a lot of creams on your face uh listen
i'm curious christian seriously like
let's say we were in the same room you
had that tool
we had some practice locks do you think
you could teach me to pick most locks
with the right tools yeah yeah i mean i
don't want to put anyone who's listening
you know uh with give them anxiety
because a lot of people do put a lot of
faith and trust into their locks and
they are secure most people don't know
this knowledge but with a little bit of
practice and the right tools yeah yeah
you could learn fairly quickly you're
smart man right tony uh
well in some areas yes in some areas
there are stunning deficits let's just
put it that way
stunning deficits is going to be the
title autobiography
you could pick it up now what about a
car
i mean cars must be impossible to get
into now right so
this actually so this type of tool the
same thing this leashi
actually
was first made for cars yeah
yeah so there's
numerous of different leashes because
there's different types of locks on cars
right so basically a lot of cars now use
i'm sorry to interrupt but a lot of cars
now use electronic uh you know they
don't have a real place for a key what
do you do with that unless it's like a
tesla yeah they will have a key for the
door handle so you just pick that you
get in if it's a push to start then all
you need is a programming tool do you
have to pass some kind of morality test
to have that locksmith tool or that
programming thing because it's uh
locksmith license and so that is
provided by the state
okay
uh all right i have a question let's say
i'm in a parking lot
uh it's late at night i lost my keys
okay
um
and
i'm stuck and i call you do you show up
in your car yeah i have a work van i was
actually originally trying to do my uh
uh my interview with you
in my work van but uh last week the
engine literally pooped out um i need a
new engine in that so i'm in a spare van
that has nothing interesting in there
why didn't you just break into someone
else's van and take it
because i tried to be a good person
conan oh well that's where you and i
diverge
these types of questions is what uh
makes me
think twice about teaching you
you're going to teach me and i want to
get that special device is it called the
schluten schleider i'm getting a
schluten slater
and i'm going to i have to have that uh
this is you david you have to get me
that tool i'm i'm on it what's it called
again it's called the lychee lychee
watch she's gonna i know david he's
gonna come back with a jar of lychee
nuts
and i'll be arrested i'll be arrested
trying to force them into the door of a
1988 bmw
what a headline though